futurama is a show that grounds itself
in the absurd and the inhabitants of the
year 3000 tend to play by different
rules to the rest of us
still there have been a few occasions on
which the cast of futurama have crossed
the line even by their standards
lying in order to avoid punishment is an
ill-advised but understandable
indiscretion and it's certainly
something of an overreach when planet
expresses robotic near-duel bender tells
authorities on chapter 9 that he
personally slaughtered a million billion
humans to avoid their wrath in season
one's fear of a bot planet a delivery to
the zealously anti-human chap 9 goes
south when bender is arrested for his
association with earthlings diabolical
monster that he is bender exaggerates
his history of mass murder in order to
exploit the population's bigotry and
propel himself to celebrity status of
course bender is a liar who hasn't
killed a million billion humans in fact
most of the stories about humankind that
he tells the gullible mechanical
citizens of chappic 9 are lifted from
vampire and werewolf legends is it true
they bite your neck and suck your
transmission fluid and then you become a
human sure why not ultimately bender
drops the act to rescue his co-worker
pals fry and leela from execution at the
hands of the council of robot elders
once the chappic 9 robots realize that
the human fry and the human-ish leela
have brought a large box of precious lug
nuts they abandon their anti-human
bigotry but it's fair to say that had
bender been left to his own devices
things might have turned out more than a
little badly
lock up your pets folks vendor bending
rodriguez is in town season 4's jurassic
bark sits atop many lists of futurama's
best episodes and for good reason it's
the heartwarming tale of fry discovering
the fossilized remains of his 20th
century canine companion seymour
ultimately fry decides against bringing
seymour back via cloning to join him in
the 31st century before fry comes to
that decision however bender throws the
fossilized pup into a nearby lava pit in
a fit of violent jealousy and sure
bender pulls the pooch out of danger
once he realizes he's totally destroyed
fry's soul by giving in to misguided
envy but still what kind of demented
sociopath tries to off a dog with molten
lava even when you take into account the
fact that robots don't have souls this
is a pretty crummy thing to do and it's
hardly the first time bender's eyes have
turned green too for similar reasons he
flushes nibbler down a toilet in season
two's i second that emotion aren't you
upset at all how would you feel if i
flushed fry down the toilet only one way
to find out
what else can you say the dude really
hates pets
bender is an amoral kleptomaniac on the
best of days but his friendship with
frye makes him look more like a lovable
rascal
most of the time at least sometimes it
simply provides bender with a
rationalization for his most overtly
super villain-ish machinations at the
conclusion of the 2008 special the beast
with a billion backs bender finds
himself resenting fry for spending so
much time with yevo a space god who is
also romancing every living creature in
the universe at once
outraged bender travels to robot hell to
recruit an army of demon robots to rise
up and conquer earth the robot devil
says no dice on an army unless bender
trades his firstborn child a deal that
bender really has no problem with
wow that was pretty brutal even by my
standards no backsies when bender
springs his unholy invasion fry informs
him that all living creatures are moving
off their planets to live on yevo's head
which is the basis for humanity's
conception of heaven not long after
still missing fry bender leads his army
of the damned to raise heaven
in the end bender's invasion spurs yevo
to break up with the universe cruelly
tearing every living thing away from its
blissful salvation in short not cool
bender
how far would you go to keep your pride
how about the pride of your entire home
planet in season three as time keeps on
slipping the harlem globetrotters fly in
from the globetrotter home world to
challenge earth to a basketball game
what happens if we lose nothing there's
nothing at stake and no threat beyond
the shame of defeat of course you
wouldn't expect this to bother professor
hubert j farnsworth as the owner of
planet express and the man directly
responsible for the appalling and
needless deaths of numerous ex-employees
he should already be completely numb to
shame rather than allow a ragtag squad
of earthlings to graciously lose an
exhibition game farnsworth sends fry
leela and bender to the far reaches of
the galaxy to collect unstable chronoton
particles upon their return he exposes
baby mutant supermen to the ominous
materials in order to age them into an
adult basketball team in an insanely
brief period of time but farnsworth's
reckless and bafflingly unnecessary
behavior causes massive damage to the
time-space continuum the linear sequence
of events begins flashing forward at
unpredictable intervals imperiling the
very matrix of reality
luckily farnsworth proves more than
capable of undoing his own mistake he
and the globetrotters join forces and
eventually figure out a solution
bringing space-time back to normal you'd
hope he'd have learned his lesson after
that but come on let's not kid ourselves
in the highly partisan era in which we
live plenty of folks will relate to zap
brannigan's unhinged contempt for the
concept of neutrality with enemies you
know where they stand but with neutrals
who knows it sickens me in season two's
brain again begin again zapp's hatred
for neutrality spills over into
delusional paranoia the democratic order
of planets invites zapp as the guest of
honor at the ribbon-cutting ceremony for
the new dupe headquarters in the neutral
zone but when the planet express crew
arrives to deliver the oversized novelty
scissors zap needs to perform his
ribbon-cutting duties zap arrests them
immediately on suspicion of neutrality
because committing civil rights
violations against the planet express
crew proves time-consuming and
distracting zap decides to save himself
a few minutes by using his spaceship's
laser set to hyper death mode to cut the
dupe hq ribbon from space and so
concludes the brief but noteworthy
existence of the new dupe headquarters
whoopsie daisy
zapp's entire presence on futurama
depends on him making breathtakingly
poor choices that force the folks around
him to mop up his messes but blowing up
dupe hq for essentially no reason at all
is going much too far even with his
track record of senseless mayhem
the version of richard nixon who appears
in futurama might not be as rotten as
the actual 37th president of the united
states but his capacity for destruction
is still very impressive in season two's
ahead in the polls richard nixon decides
to get back in the political game and
run for president of earth like many
other celebrities and historical figures
in the 31st century nixon's existence is
limited to that of a floating head in a
jar due to the decomposed condition of
his old body much of the episode's story
revolves around nixon's technically
legal use of bender's robot body but
once bender reclaims his torso arms and
legs nixon simply acquires a much larger
body equipped with devastating weapon
systems
nixon's back
[Applause]
this gundam-esque nixon locks down the
robot vote and becomes the new president
of earth still bitter and crazy from his
infamous near impeachment and
resignation over the watergate scandal
nixon embarks on a rampage of death and
destruction throughout the city of
washington dc the nation of earth may
never fully recover
when a man lives his first 20-something
years as a dangerously broke pizza
delivery technician he's bound to cut
loose if his luck ever swings in the
opposite direction so it's
understandable why fry shamelessly
flaunts his wealth when the interest on
his thousand-year-old bank account makes
him a billionaire in season ones a fish
full of dollars now plenty of people
will tell you that taxidermy is in
pretty poor taste and collecting
skeletons really isn't much less creepy
and sure enough when fry pays ten
thousand dollars at an auction for the
skeleton of stalwart television actor
ted danson you've got to admit he's kind
of crossing a line fry's newfound ocean
of cash and pre-existing 90s nostalgia
coalesces into a turn of events that
introduces the evil company known as mom
corp danson's bones are only mentioned
in a one-off gag as fry says he needs
them because he's got an idea for a
sitcom but the fact that fry treats the
remains of a once living person like
this demonstrates exactly how far down
the rabbit hole he has fallen
anyone will tell you how much it sucks
to miss out on the finale of your
favorite show but when ler ruler of the
planet omicron persei 8 is prevented
from watching the last episode of single
female lawyer after a technical glitch
on earth he overreacts just a tad
the trajectory of events depicted in
season ones when aliens attack is set in
motion before the opening credits as fry
often ends up at the center of universe
altering events in futurama it tracks
that he was the one who spilled beer on
the late 90s fox control panel
eventually cutting off the broadcast
omicronians who are watching 1 000 light
years away
to extract his revenge and enforce his
will ler swoops down to earth and
immediately destroys the eiffel tower
the great sphinx of giza the leaning
tower of pisa and other prominent earth
landmarks he pulls off all of that in
pretty rapid succession too though
that's mostly because they've all been
relocated to the same beach in new new
york independence day eat your heart out
anyway ler gets to see his program by
the episode's end mostly thanks to a
little creativity by the planet express
crew talk about a temper tantrum though
over time societies change and behavior
considered taboo in one era might be
acceptable during another but there are
some things that cross a line no matter
where or when you come from grave
robbing definitely belongs in that
category especially if that grave
belongs to a family member in season
three is the luck of the fryrish fry is
horrified to discover a 21st century man
named philip j fry who looks just like
him took possession of his long-lost
seven leaf clover worse still this
impostor apparently became a globally
famous astronaut and rock star fry
assumes this paragon of human
achievement must be his brother yancey
who would have had access to the clover
and knowledge of its near supernatural
powers while in the process of digging
up what he thinks is his elder siblings
corpse however fry notices the
gravestone's inscription
here lies philip j fry
named for his uncle
to carry on his spirit
this happens just in time for bender to
break open the coffin and snag the lucky
clover it's an embarrassing mix up to be
sure but it's also a lesson to the rest
of us that grave robbing is kind of a
no-no no matter what your robotic best
friend might tell you
fry transgresses the boundaries of
decency in a whole new way in season 3's
roswell that ends well in this episode
fry accidentally sends the planet
express ship back to the 1940s where it
crashes in roswell new mexico plenty of
hijinks ensue zoidberg gets vivisected
farnsworth and lila go shopping and
bender becomes
whatever this is but fry's dalliance
with history is the most impressive of
all during his relatively short time in
the past fry manages to accidentally
kill his grandfather deliberately sleep
with his grandmother and accidentally
impregnate her with the fetus that
eventually becomes fry's father yancy
fry senior
[Music]
the events of this episode reverberate
throughout the mythology of futurama in
fact fry's status as his own grandfather
is unbeknownst to everybody but nibbler
the real reason why he's in the future
in the first place the alterations made
to fry's brain by doing the nasty and
the pasty later makes him the ideal
candidate to defeat the evil species
known as brain spawn and save the entire
universe it also makes him a total
doofus but hey you win some you lose
some
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one